grazie eccolo ciao ciao a tutti ciao
padova città dove per me tutto è
cominciato io ho studiato qui al
dipartimento di matematica ormai quasi
dieci anni fa credo prima di espatriare
amsterdam un po i parigini poi londra è
oggi molto più che allora si sente
parlare di arduino di ras prima e di
tutte questa incredibile
democratizzazione di piattaforme che ci
permettono senza troppo sforzo di creare
i nostri micro computer e di adattarli
per le nostre particolari esigenze come
individui
quindi chiunque oggi può applicare
qualunque tipo di sensore da dal sensore
al battito cardiaco
all al tempo atmosferico la posizione
geografica eccetera eccetera ha un sacco
di cose all'antifurto del garage oppure
a al telecomando della cir comando della
televisione in salotto eccetera
e io credo davvero che oggi un ragazzino
di 18 20 anni riesca se sveglio riesca a
crearsi su arduino in grado di fare un
sacco di cose in grado di mandargli un
sms le cellulare appena i genitori
entrano in casa per esempio oppure che
seriamente magari dei sistemi che
permettono di annaffiare le piante in
maniera automatica appena la terra
diventa troppo arida eccetera eccetera
eccetera
e io credo che questo sia il futuro sia
la tecnologia in grado di essere
adattata ai nostri bisogni specifici
come individui quindi alcuni anni fa
durante il dottorato che fatto thrier
cam centro pompidou di parigi e
goldsmith università di londra mi è
sorta questa domanda è possibile
applicare questa rivoluzione al mondo
della musica al mondo degli strumenti
musicali è possibile fare una sorta di
rivoluzione copernicana in cui anziché
essere noi a dover apprendere un insieme
di regole prestabilite dall'inventore di
uno strumento musicale
e poi ovviamente consolidata nel corso
degli anni e dei secoli lo farei uno
strumento è in grado di essere adattato
alle nostre esigenze come individui
particolari specifici e allora ha fatto
mille esperimenti o ne siamo provato con
accelerometri telecamere
termine giroscopio sacco di sensore
diversi
finché a un certo punto ho avuto questa
idea perché non anziché creare uno
strumento finalizzato perché non creare
un meta strumento una sorta di
tecnologia che in un attimo permette a
chiunque di trasformare in strumento
musicale qualunque cosa abbia già
attorno a lui e quindi diciamo è stato
allora che ho avuto la per creare magis
che è questo questa nuova tecnologia che
è
composta da un piccolo sensore come come
questo
un peso trasduttore che posso
appiccicare a qualunque oggetto voglio e
lui cerca di trasformare tutte le micro
vibrazioni che noi facciamo quando
tocchiamo questo oggetto in un segnale
elettrico che viene inviato al mio
smartphone oppure al mio computer torre
un software lo trasforma in musica in
tempo reale come fa a fare questa cosa
allora immaginiamoci il suono di una
chitarra ad esempio allora il suono
della chitarra viene generato
dall'impatto dei due corpi un plettro e
amato exciter e la corda stessa della
chitarra chiamate ha reso network qui il
magis è più o meno la stessa cosa dove
qualunque vibrazione
io faccio quando tocco qualunque oggetto
viene usato come exciter viene catturata
dal sensore e poi e poi il resto network
viene emulato nel software
quindi io posso scegliere quanto
preservare e quanto alterare le
proprietà acustiche innate dell'oggetto
stesso quindi per esempio demo io
accendo la up
sono queste rocce che loro volta
centralmente ieri a mia mamma in salotto
ok fantastico quindi io posso creare il
suono che voglio dall'oggetto che voglio
è essere ispirato dal diciamo delle
proprietà dell'oggetto stesso però manca
ancora qualcosa secondo me non sarebbe
fantastico riuscire ad assegnare delle
note diverse dei timbri diverse in base
al tipo di tocco che faccio
ed è qui che entra in ballo il concetto
di machine learning che è un termine che
forse avete già sentito che come dice la
parola stessa vuol dire macchina pure
tecnologia in grado di apprendere in
questo caso ho applicato il mondo del
machine learning alla musica o diciamo
creato una tecnologia in grado di essere
adattate ed imparare i gesti che noi
vogliamo eseguire quindi ora faccio un
demo in cui insegno al software un certo
numero di gesti ad esempio suonare quel
l'unghia per esempio questa luce sarà il
mio primo gesto suonare con la rocca
sarà il mio secondo gesto sono regole il
pollice sarà il mio terzo gesto ad
esempio ok
e ora
grazie
concludo dicendo che più o meno un anno
fa
o mi sono trasformato questa idea questo
prototipo in un vero progetto quindi o
diciamo dato vita a una campagna online
di crowd funding su kickstarter che
andata benissimo la ta volte le più
rosee aspettative abbiamo incassato più
del doppio del numero di unità che
volevamo vendere e ora grazie anche a
persone che hanno creduto e che credono
ancora oggi tantissimo in questo
progetto e alcune di loro sono oggi
nella sala andrea gallo francesco della
rovere ruggero frezza di m31 incubatore
qui di padova
finalmente dopo tanti anni tanta fatica
finalmente sarà sarà disponibile al
pubblico tra pochissime settimane grazie